hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt sind heute machen wir endlich
endlich die spina taschen aus dem film
ein königreich für ein lama ich hab mich
in den kommentaren so oft gefragt ob ich
mal nachmachen kann und ich mache es
sehr gerne weil erstens dass mein
absoluter liebling sleep links
lieblingsfilm war als kind natürlich
habe ich auch noch andere lieblingsfilme
aber gerade diesen film hatte ich als
videokassette und weil wir früher ein
bisschen ärger waren habe ich halt nicht
so viele videokassetten oder spielsachen
und diesen film hatte ich und ich habe
mir so oft angeschaut und zweitens und
mein gott ist das etwa eine werbung ja
sky hat mich nämlich gefragt ob ich
nicht wieder lust habe euch ein kleines
paket vorzustellen und zwar ist es
dieses mal das thema ticket und
entertainment ticket also filme und
serien schauen für zwei monate und zwar
für nur 999 natürlich könnte jetzt
wieder monatlich kündigen also bis
august könnt ihr dann zwei monate für 99
der sky entertainment ticket und das
geist in dem artikel schauen ist das
nicht einfach nur klasse
für mich gab wie so eine tv logic ja und
natürlich gibt es da nicht nur ein
königreich für ein lama was ich ganz
besonders teufeln also wenn ihr nach dem
rezept lust habt er den finger zu
schauen oder davor war dann wohl durch
das ticket der link dazu ist unten und
es gibt natürlich nicht nur diesen film
sondern auch natürlich die serie
game of thrones und west world die ich
auch sehr empfehlen kann natürlich könnt
ihr auch filme schauen wie valerien und
zwei damen homecoming und dank hört den
ich sogar im kino geschaut hat und der
1a superklasse war ein bisschen heavy
ein bisschen viel aber super coolen mich
jetzt jemand wie david heyl hören würde
dank war super cool ihr wisst was ich
meine und wenn ihr zum beispiel im
urlaub sei dann könnte ja sogar der
ganzen wm stream also schaut in den
ersten link in der beschreibung da
werdet ihr weitergeleitet und jetzt geht
es weiter mit dem video bei solchen
rezepten finde ich es immer ganz wichtig
herauszufinden was da reinkommen sollte
und was nicht und wie es ungefähr
zubereitet werden muss
und da gibt es schon glaube ich zwei
videos die ich auf youtube gefunden habt
von zwei youtube channel die diese
spielerischen gemacht haben allerdings
haben beide kanäle mit blätterteig
gearbeitet da ein königreich für ein
lama in peru spielt und zur inka zeit
spielen sollte glaube ich nicht dass die
blätterteig benutzt haben bzw sollte man
da aufpassen was man für teig benutzt es
heißt nämlich im englischen spinne papst
im englischen macht schon sinn dass man
dann blätterteig benutzt aber ich hab
mal gegoogelt was so spezielle
peruanische rezepte sind oder
teigtaschen und da werden im pana das
vorgestellt im pana das sind einfach
teigtaschen die meistens aus maismehl
sind was sogar gut zu den inkas passt
weil die weisheiten und kartoffeln und
spinat hatten sie glaube ich auch schon
auf jeden fall habe ich dann viel über
peru gelegen und die inkas und was da so
rein kommen könnte und für unsere
spieler taschen brauchen wie er meist
mehl backpulver auch wenn sie
wahrscheinlich nicht backpulver hatten
glaube ich dass krank da trotzdem
irgendein zugang zu hatte weil sie auf
brokkoli hatten und ich weiß nicht kaum
brokkoli aus peru gab es bei den inkas
schon brokkoli die disney zeichner waren
nicht so ordentlich mit ihrer recherche
deswegen sind wir auch nicht so
ordentlich mit der recherche verdammt
150 gerade butter ich würde es gerne in
die luft werden ob ich traurig nicht 1 1
und was natürlich staat hoffen denn wir
brauchen etwas um die farbe heller zu
machen denn die füllung bike spinat
taschen ist nämlich eher sohn hank und
wenn man spinat mixen würde zu seiner
pampel ersten dunkelgrün und deswegen
brauchen wir etwas um die farbe
aufzuhellen und kartoffeln sind sehr
traditionell peruanisch denn wie wachsen
da schon ganz lange zwiebeln kam zwar
erst im 16 jahrhundert aber wie gesagt
die disney zeichner waren auch nicht so
gründlich das heißt für den geschmack
machen wir auch ein bischen zwiebel
rhein alles für den geschmack vielleicht
machen wir auch noch ein bisschen bei
mir ein wenn der teig nicht so möchte
wie wir wollen
und zu guter letzt lama käse ich meine
schafskäse oder ziegenkäse weil die ja
auch so nutzt tierarten und das einen
guten geschmack sind säure rhein gibt
also let's go mal kartoffeln ziemlich
lange brauchen werden wir sie schon mal
aufsetzen und krachen
jetzt kümmern wir uns um den teig
ich habe noch nie mit maismehl gekocht
dann machen wir ein bisschen backpulver
rein und 250 gramm butter kommt jetzt
einfach so rein und diese mischungen
müssen wir jetzt kneten mit den händen
oder lich mit einer zeitmaschine
daraus ist ein eiweiß und wasser und ja
ich finde es witzig wie mir die leute
unter meinem letzten helicobacter video
geschrieben haben dass sie enttäuscht
und mancher eigentlich so gut backen und
kochen kann und das ist dann nichts
geworden ist und dass ich mühe gegeben
haben so getan als ob das nicht könnte
laut konnte es wirklich mich neue sachen
sind wirklich schwer die eine und heute
ist gut gelungen weil ich jetzt schon
mittlerweile zehn torten als videos
gemacht habe und die einen rotor darin
gezeigt dass dazugelernt habe erklärte
habe ich noch nie gemacht in kanada teil
habe ich auch noch nie gemacht das ist
lernprozess wie bei allem es gelb ist
wird auch niemand geboren und kann
perfekt malen oder singen es gibt schon
heute aber selbst lieber auf die übung
okay das ist doch keine gute idee mit
dem 1
[Musik]
das sind unser zeitfahren lag um den
kühlschrank mit ihnen besser verarbeiten
können
wir müssen uns den spinat kochen wie
kaufmann spinat in einem topf
[Musik]
man kocht spieler riecht man bringt ihn
um mein gott ich habe keine ahnung wie
viel wir auch spinat muss jetzt
gewaschen werden
spinat jetzt gewaschen so spinat
zwiebeln wenig zwiebelschneiden durch
mir lieber nicht jagen zu jedem film ein
königreich für ein lama als kind gesehen
oder vielleicht letztens erst 2011 im
rausch bekomme ich bin 93 das heißt ich
war sieben oder acht sich dinge gesehen
habt ja das kann auch hinkommen hier
sind die zwiebeln
jetzt müssen wir das sie anbraten ja das
war hinten könnt ihr mal wieder nicht
sehen ist schick und praktisch ich kenne
zu euch rüber rufen einmal öl in die
pfanne und die zwiebeln rein in die
heiße pfanne kommt jetzt auf der spieler
hat er passt nicht so viel wert wie
fällt das fehlen von ok
das sind so gesund aus ich brauche ein
paar kartoffeln und spinat von vp
hiermit unsere dürfen und unseren spinat
und das muss jetzt alles gemixt werden
du bist so ein richtiger mixa
wir brauchen auf jeden fall spielen
[Musik]
wow jetzt müssen wir das tun weil ich
hoffe doch ich stehe ja ich weiß gar
nicht darf man heiße kartoffel nixon
gibt es da irgendein gesetz kommen leute
ich ran verkaufen aber es gibt nicht für
alles man kann nicht alles wissen außer
vielleicht tim mälzer oder so
wenigstens klein gemacht werden
und natürlich auch 100 kampfstier sind
als ob ich wüsste was ich jetzt das wird
super stecken okay man bei körperlich
ein bisschen käse auf jeden fall muss
die farbe noch heller werden denn auf
dem bild seht ihr das nicht zu dunkel
ist es nämlich der unterschied zu mir
und den ganzen anderen kanälen die
serien funk machen die versuchung nicht
wirklich ist nach zu machen die machen
halt eine eigene version davon
das ist so brie wieder in bagdad ich
muss aber auch sagen es schmeckt extrem
die baby für wärme ist noch mal und
hoffe dass so ein bisschen flüssigkeit
verdampft damit es eine feste masse wird
es macht sinn oder das macht sinn
es ist auf jeden fall eine kopie gemacht
vielleicht muss ich auch nochmal
kartoffeln reis okay mit dieser mache
können wir arbeiten geil das ist jetzt
richtig wie knete oh mein gott oh mein
gott mein t shirt aus ich sollte
wirklich mal meine kochschürze koch
schützenwirt rausbringt moritz
kochschürzen merge nämlich mahlweizen
jeweils im gewässer funktioniert legen
wir die da rein wo ich habe so ein
rezept im internet gefunden das nicht so
richtig was muss eine komische seite war
ich wollte seite vertrauen seite war
sehr komisch
ich brauche ein tag den ich träume zu
machen kann befeuchtet zu sehr aus raste
mache ich mal ein paar experimente und
melde mich gleich wieder
es wird alles gut es wird alles gut es
wird alles gut so in voller panik habe
ich jetzt noch zwei reingemacht ein
bisschen maisstärke noch an weizenmehl
und jetzt hoffe ich wirklich das ist
funktioniert weiterhin peter zeit aber
das ist besser als das was es feuer war
wie es machen
ich habe schon echt mich heulend in der
ecke wisse wie gar nicht um das ist den
bullen hier mitnehmen was von unserer
grünen kamberi aussieht wie auf ich will
mir das so zurecht ich am ende seien
seit so und dann rolle ich es einfach
jetzt so über das weingut ist es eine
ziemlich dicke ende mein gott es ist
riesig und verbessert die richtigen
größe hubraum dass sie den film nicht so
gebraten aus weil das noch so ein heller
tag ist was ich denn jetzt frittieren
dann wird das nix muss in den ofen okay
jetzt machen wir sind offen und ich
mache noch die anderen taschen fertig
und dann hat es in den ofen und dann
sehen wir uns gleich mit dem ergebnis
wieder
das müsste jetzt nicht sehen und jetzt
hier sind die spina taschen aus
königreich für ein lama besucher ist
wirklich interessant mit nichts
vergleichen was ich bisher gebrochen
habe weil wir uns gut ist
gut sie sehen ich eins zu eins aus wie
das original aber die füllung macht
schon echt was her oh mein gott das
sieht aus wie dieses gezeichnete also
bisher nicht meine
das sind halt aus wie das was er da hier
wir brauchen den vergleich und hat auch
diese gute farbe ich glaube es war
wirklich richtig ist zu backen handys
frittierte die richtige empanadas dann
wäre das nicht so schön worden
ich lasse jetzt auf jeden fall noch
abkühlen und in der zeit erzähle ich
euch noch mal etwas
denn wenn ihr zum beispiel einen film
oder serienabend euren freunden plant
und eines meiner wie schmeckt rezepte
nach macht dann verlinkt mich gerne
darauf instagram und wenn ihr noch nicht
wisst wo ihr das schauen sollte den film
oder die serie dann kam ich euch nur das
sky ticket entertainment und sky cinema
ticket sehr ans herz legen also einmal
serien schauen und einmal filme schauen
für neun euro 99 zwei monate lang und
noch ein bisschen was im juni und die
können in der ganzen eu falls im urlaub
zeit ist einfach mitnehmen und irgendwo
auf malle oder so anschauen wo auch
immer ihr wollt ja link ist der erste in
der beschreibung und jetzt werden wir es
probieren
und nun stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
kommt spinat asche aus ein königreich
für ein lama
guten appetit
[Musik]
lecker ich weiß nicht was sie für eine
art tag erfunden habe
durch diesen unfall den ich dann
versucht zu retten was ist einfach so
weiss weiter mit butter und eiern mega
gut es hat echt ein paar mehr gewürze
dran sein können aber ich wollte jetzt
nicht zu viel wein machen weil ich nicht
wusste was in peru an gewürzen so
vorhanden war deswegen habe ich einfach
mit seit simpel gelassen und damit heute
nach dem letzten helicobacter video das
ich meine muse ist dahin und ich kann
nie wieder kochen oder backen aber ich
denke mal das lässt sich wirklich sehen
und das allerbeste es sieht wirklich aus
wie das fach im original
ich bin so stolz ich bin nämlich auch
mit